The joe rogan experience.
They say that infinity is so intense,
like the idea of infinity and this is the best way to wrap your head around it.
If infinity Israel,
that means that in the universe not only has everything that we've said in the
exact same order and the exact same pauses in the exact same
timeframe and fuck up of words or slip of the tongue,
it's happened exactly that way in exactly that order.
An infinite number of times,
not just one,
but an infinite number of times that everything that's ever taken place down to
the millisecond has not just happened once somewhere else,
but infinite times somewhere else.
Wow.
That's how big infinity is.
That's what no end means.
That's so weird.
Like it just like when you're doing some mundane thing like jerking off,
coming to porn.
I'm just thinking this is infinite.
It's an infinite loop of Tj's that's happening.
Oh,
shins,
oceans of ges.
You could just see like just a universe filled with you squirting ah,
fractal,
like literally a universe that's real like so the sky would be absolutely filled
from horizon to horizon with with you coming more than this.
All the come from all the Dunkin's in all over the world at once.
Drenched the earth.
We would drown and seaman.
Oh,
how's the entire population would drown.
We would be coded in like a million miles thick of com because if you think
about what infinity means,
how many different Dunkin's would be coming,
there's no end to it.
So one ounce of calm equals 100 billion oceans filled with come instantaneously
raining down upon those oceans would be filled with more me's coming.
So not only that,
the universe itself would not be big enough to contain the earth size.
Just from the sheer amount of calm it was covered it.
Yeah,
it would push the atmosphere way past the sun.
It would light the earth on fire and turn it into a big come.
One of those fucking hush puppy.
It was a big come hush puppy when the come got so big.
It touched the side of the deep fryer is so big,
it touches this time and then puts the sun out and presses out into the outer
galaxy.
That's how much come.
And then infinite amount of people coming in.
And then some,
like some God chef would just come and eat it.
It's just not a cooking show.
And,
and then,
you know,
he lives in another world where you're coming on and it just goes on forever.
No,
that's how you impregnate the sun.
You fill up planet with come to the,
stop up a black hole.
We don't know what to do about a black hole.
We're going to get an infinite amount of Dunkin's to come in it.
Well,
it's,
you know,
mass broken down to the smallest part.
Uh,
it's not going to stop an infinite amount of carb.
Trust me,
there's a whole other universe inside.
They're still not big enough for infinite amounts of calm.
Sorry.
The black holes,
like what the fuck?
The black hole is like Sasha drag and the fucking giant black cock being force
fed while she's lying on her back.
Snots going down into her eyelashes.
That's the he lived verse is
so symbolic.
So some bog of gag porn,
you're coming into a black hole,
the fucking whole of Van and starts sputtering.
No,
that's spinning.
The spinning of the black hole absorbing matter just gets all choked up like a
fucking,
like,
like a dishwasher disposal system with a spoon in it.
You know when those garbage disposals,
the spoon drops in it.
You scared to put your hand in there to try to unstop it.
Do you think,
and that's how the universe was created.
His infinite,
infinite come looped went into a black hole.
Do you think that ever come into a black hole in the future?
Oh yeah.
If we live long enough,
someone's going to want to do that.
They're gonna want to be the first guy,
some Richard Branson type asshole,
the first guy to show the world.
I want to inspire you that you too can come in a black hole.
Him with a fucking black socks on.
So I always come,
he sends like a shuttle from his pod and he's got like,
it's like a glory hole into the next shuttle and he's wearing an aqua man t
shirt.
It's way too small and he's a little slightly embarrassing roll of fat,
pulls out of the bar of like a little waterfall and he's just jerking off with
his black socks on into it until
you never know until you try.
I seek to inspire.
I'm seeking to inspire you that you too humble,
man.